from timcast.com
North Dakota man admits to running over
and killing teenager for allegedly being
part of a republican extremist group
this is crazy for a variety of reasons
look it's only it's been a couple weeks
since Joe Biden said that Maga
Republicans were an extremist threat to
this country and we said that's that's
dangerous rhetoric that's the kind of
tribalist rhetoric that results in
violence the left likes to claim oh
Donald Trump's engaging in stochastic
terrorism and what he's saying is going
to result in violence against
journalists no less now what stories did
we get a Democrat is allegedly uh isma
is arrested for allegedly murdering a
journalist
and then it is what I can only assume is
some unhinged liberal who runs he runs
down he hunted this kid down the kid
apparently called his mom saying he
needed help because the guy was chasing
him down
and then he chased him into an alley and
crushed him with an SUV because he was a
republican extremist this kid alleged
extremist alleged well right he accused
him of being a republican extremist part
of a republican extremist group that's
was his justification this guy it's a
cult these people have paranoid
delusions Joe Biden is inflaming them
and yet they keep pointing the finger at
the the dude in the Maga had sitting in
his lounge chair drinking a beer
watching the game problem pointing a
finger at any group is like and I'm
going to use the the age-old Nazi
metaphor but like people are like I
heard this meme going around punch a
Nazi in like 2018 I'm like okay this is
a bad road to go down you might think
that the Nazis were the bad guys and
maybe they were but the Nazis thought
the Jews were the bad guys and they
thought the Jews were an extremist
radical organization that they wanted to
remove from the country you see how that
went when you start persecuting groups
of people
it can be very very bad it's tribalism
it's our side is the good side and these
people are evil the only problem is
there there there is truth and there is
fiction and so what do we have here we
have a show like this granted we engage
in tribalist rhetoric often as well but
I think there's a difference for one we
say things like hey those guys who are
violent on January 6 should be arrested
and prosecuted
what do we hear from Kamala Harris and
Joe Biden their staff and Kamal Harris
and personally bail these people out we
see Violent rights coming across the
country what do we get justification
that what do we get Chris Cuomo saying
who said protests need to be peaceful
you get calls from the corporate press
the mainstream media justifying calling
it a peaceful protest and you get us
begging them to stop even saying that
the the Trump people on January 6 should
be charged as well when you've got a
right that's saying we want the violence
to end and a left encouraging it the
left then blaming the right but the left
is actually got the ones who are
literally running people in down Aaron
Danielson shot and killed yeah there is
a serious problem and there is a tribal
problem and this is not the first time
that this happened there's a number of
incidences in Washington in in Portland
all throughout the United States and
Colorado I remember seeing footage of of
you know someone getting shot I remember
there's other footage of a man at a part
of a BLM anti-far rally that was hiding
uh behind a wall that came out and shot
someone because of their political
opinions there's a number of people that
of course were shot were killed were
executed for their political beliefs and
seeing this in the United States is
absolutely horrible because the United
States is supposed to represent Free
Speech it's supposed to represent a
country where we could talk through our
differences and be able to speak freely
and be able to accept each other for our
political differences but now we're
meeting speech with guns and people
shooting each other which is absolutely
crazy religious differences too
sometimes people will say that America
is a Christian Nation but it's not it's
a nation where you're allowed to be
Christian
I well it's built on the foundation of
Christianity though yeah yeah I mean
Christians built the foundation but it
was the idea that anyone could practice
any religion here with the Christians as
they were building it yeah no no I'm
sorry I I was just going to say you know
everybody keeps talking about how badly
we all need to be communicating with
each other but when you see things like
this and all the instances that you just
listed off I mean this is why people
keep their voting preferences private
this is why people don't want to engage
people are they're actually scared
I I mentioned this Earl on my earlier
segment about Bill Burr because he did
uh he was on trigonometry and a bunch of
there were a bunch of Articles written
about it and people were quote tweeting
him and stuff like that where he said
you know this hate online isn't real go
outside take some smell some fresh air
people aren't fighting they're not angry
like they are online
and it's just he's wrong yeah and as I
explained it is
people in Liberal cities aren't fighting
with each other for the most part
sometimes they do they're right that's
right it's people in conservative areas
aren't fighting with each other
sometimes but usually not
but if you look where the two sides meet
there's Clash Chick-fil-A being a good
example a fast food chicken restaurant
but the the people who run it were
making donations to Christian
organizations so what happens the left
shows up and they are belligerent I
don't want to say violent because
they're mostly just protesting these
buildings but you actually see when Ann
Coulter goes to uh Berkeley or goes to
New Jersey to speak and they all show up
in those riots I think it was when Milo
was going to speak at Berkeley they
actually started setting fires and
smashing Windows spray painting threats
to liberals even so that kind of stuff
you know that's
I don't know you made a good metaphor
that's what's happening before the show
about the bill birthing because like
you're saying we're we as you know
journalists and watching the news are
like in a watchtower and we see little
bits of chaos around pockets of it so
for Bill to walk outside and not see it
in his immediate surroundings and claim
that it doesn't exist is a problem it's
it's inaccurate it's an assumption that
Bill's making because it does exist and
you you're right so I I don't want to
inflame it and make people start
fighting because but I do want to
acknowledge that these things it's not
like it's not happening you know we
gotta we gotta find out why it's
happening and maybe we can provide
comfort and and reasons to you know not
happen you know
basically what I was saying was uh this
show is us standing on a watchtower and
we can see off in the distance we can
see people fighting in pockets and we're
like we don't know if that fighting will
come here but we know it is happening
all throughout the land we can see
fighting emerge and when we when we when
we shout down to the people who are at
the ground level and we're like hey
there's a crazy fighting happening
billboard goes what are you talking
about everybody having a good time and
we're up here like yeah but the
fighting's getting crazier and like
there's more people and on their flights
like nah you're crazy it's totally fine
and then it's sooner or later it may or
may it might come here it might not I
don't know you don't need to live in a
state of constant fear and anguish over
it but to deny it is worrisome I think
that it cath I think it has come here
and I feel like the guy driving this SUV
who killed this poor kid oh my gosh my
heart breaks over this was probably blue
Anon he's probably on Twitter getting
all fired up and he's taken out to the
real world I think this is also the guy
who shot that guy in Portland and the
probably what happened in Denver too
that Luke was referring to earlier I
think it's coming to the real world is
there any evidence if it was personal
between these two guys he knew the guy's
kid's mom apparently apparently the mom
knew who he was I don't know if they
knew each other
but uh apparently what happened was it
was a street dance party the kid was
leaving they had some political words
between each other probably something
like fjb or F Donald Trump or something
who knows and then this adult 41 year
old man confronted an 18 year old the
kids got spiky hair and braces yo be an
adult be a man and be alike get out of
here kid I got time for this walk away
don't no no no the dude gets in his car
and starts hunting the kid down the kid
calls his mom and says he needs help
because the guy's chasing after him the
dude then follows him to an alley runs
him over crushes him killing him and by
the time the mom gets there she finds
her son deadly horrible it makes me sick
you know you know what I think
and I understand the problem of you know
recognizing the problem of tribalism but
being part of the problem with tribalism
there's nothing you can do about it I
view it as that that old um riddle you
come across a fork in the road and there
are two men you know one on the left and
one on the right one always tells the
truth and one always lies
and that's what I feel like what we're
dealing with
the Democrats overwhelmingly as an
organization and the neocon Republicans
you know party trash people like Lindsey
Graham are just liars just outright
Liars the culture War right tends to be
honest and truthful the culture War left
tends to be deceitful and manipulative
it doesn't mean every person on the left
is deceitful and manipulative and
doesn't mean every person on the right
is honest but there's tendency there's
the rule and the exception so when you
see Joe Biden come out and say that my
Republican extremists are a threat to
our country
and not a peep from the left about
stochastic terrorism but celebration
then Donald Trump comes out and goes you
have fake news and they go he's going to
get a journalist killed so criticizing
the media's terrorism but Joe Biden
calling half the country extremists who
are going to destroy this country is to
be celebrated it's to be accountability
I have no problem saying yeah Donald
Trump's rhetoric I did I wasn't a big
fan of and and I constantly heard from
people that he was too Brash and too
aggressive and things like that and I
think Rhonda Sanchez has more attack
that's why I'm kind of leaning towards
him I have no problem criticizing what I
think is bad and then I have no problem
criticizing Joe Biden but one side will
outright always just keep defending
themselves keep defending themselves no
matter how bad they are no matter what
they do no matter who they kill no
matter how much damage they cause it
seems to them they've done nothing wrong
why they have one goal in its power yeah
I think the people in the know on the
left or in in control of the media
whatever this is is they're they're over
seeing like an old guard the liberal
economic order which is about to
manipulate change into a world economic
order
um and so they're willing to lie to
protect it and to make sure they guide
it the way they want to guide it the
people that are voting for that I don't
think are
in understand what's happening they're
just kind of following what they're
comfortable with and Donald Trump made
them very uncomfortable so I was I was
kind of thinking about this earlier I
was like why is it that they seem to be
totally unmoored from reality and I
think at the left is in fact unmoored
the right
you can call me biased I definitely am I
think that we actually have a grasp of
objective truth and I think that's why
you can make an argument from the right
and be like well I think this is
entirely the case here's why I have news
articles for you they'll just dismiss
you they don't care what you show them
you can show them CNN and they don't
give a crap what you have to say because
they're convinced Tim talks about it
being a cult
I don't know if Colt is the right word
it feels like they've been brainwashed
like they've given a lot of the
responsibility for what they do over to
someone else which I guess you could
call a cult but thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there